Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Sono Daniele Manni,
insegno informatica da 25 anni
presso l'Istituto
"Galilei Costa" di Lecce.
E grazie al tema di questo TEDx
ho scoperto di essere un condi-visionario.
Sì, perché la mia vita di docente
è stata caratterizzata
da tre grandi condi-visioni.
Anzi no, due virgola uno
grandi condivisioni.
Mi esprimo con un numero decimale
perché due di queste
sono già in atto da diverso tempo,
mentre la terza è stata appena concepita,
e ve la annuncerò
fra pochi minuti su questo palco.
La mia storia inizia a metà degli anni '80
quando, dopo la laurea
e parallelamente all'insegnamento,
decido di dare sfogo
alla mia natura di "intraprenditore".
Non divento cioè un imprenditore
ma piuttosto un intraprenditore,
a cui piace creare nuove imprese,
inventarsele, portarle avanti,
portarle al successo o al fallimento
e poi abbandonarle, lasciarle,
prenderne una nuova,
intraprendere una nuova.
Dall '86 al '99 ho co-fondato
quattro diverse aziende.
Due di queste sono miseramente terminate,
le altre due stanno facendo
sempre più ricchi i miei ex soci.
(Risate)
E arriviamo nel '99.
Nel '99 nasce la mia prima condivisione.
Nel '99 decido di dare
una svolta radicale alla mia vita,
smetto l'intraprendenza
esterna alla scuola
e decido di portare
tutte le mie esperienze,
tutto il know-how,
dentro la scuola,
cioè decido di condividere
con i miei studenti le mie esperienze.
E non mi limito semplicemente
a raccontare loro quello che ho fatto,
e come l'ho fatto;
al contrario, inizio insieme a loro
a creare nuove piccole imprese,
cercando di tradurle tutte
in imprese reali.
Oggi queste vengono chiamate start-up.
Ma per fare questo,
e fate molta attenzione,
perché sto per fare coming out,
per fare questo sono diventato
un insegnante "fuorilegge".
Ho abbandonato completamente,
assolutamente
tutti i programmi ministeriali.
E ho deciso, da quel momento,
di portare avanti argomenti
che interessavano a me.
Decidevo io, volta per volta,
cosa affrontare con i ragazzi.
E ho dedicato circa la metà
delle mie ore di lezione
a materie inesistenti, inconsistenti.
Parlo di innovazione,
creatività, sperimentazione.
Dopo poco tempo, insieme
alla mia compagna e collega,
e a 16 studenti di quinta superiore,
decidiamo di dare vita ad Arianoa.
Arianoa, nel nostro dialetto locale,
significa aria nuova.
E Arianoa è una vera e propria
società cooperativa,
utile ed indispensabile
a mettere realmente, concretamente,
legalmente in atto
le piccole startup dei nostri ragazzi.
Arianoa è una cosa piuttosto innovativa:
viene notata e diffusa
anche attraverso un bellissimo
progetto di generatività
curato dall'Università Cattolica di Milano
e dall'Istituto "Luigi Sturzo".
Una cosa innovativa,
che oggi chiamiamo "incubatore"
e "acceleratore" di start up giovanili.
Undici anni fa,
era semplicemente una visione.
Da allora, i nostri ragazzi
hanno creato, curato, gestito,
e quasi sempre fatto fallire
oltre 20 start-up,
oltre 20 piccole imprese.
Oggi, di quelle, sono soltanto tre
a essere sopravvissute,
a vivere, a proliferare
e a creare un reddito
per i ragazzi che l'hanno creata.
E a voler ricavare una sorta
di percentuale di sopravvivenza,
ci attestiamo intorno al 13%.
E pare che sia un'ottima percentuale.
Adesso, mi piacerebbe condividere con voi
alcune di queste start-up.
Mi piacerebbe che vi rendeste conto
di come sia facile, semplice, a volte,
che e1 possibile trasformare in business
alcune piccole idee
che vengono create, inventate
sulla lavagna di un'aula scolastica.
La prima che vi presento
è il Festival della dieta Med-italiana.
Questo festival sono quattro anni
che i ragazzi lo organizzano.
Occupano la piazza maggiore
della città, a Lecce,
riescono a convogliare
oltre 60 piccole aziende agroalimentari,
di qualità, del territorio,
e contemporaneamente
riescono a far venire, in quei giorni,
migliaia di turisti
perché hanno abbinato questo festival
a una formula turistica innovativa:
si chiama 30-20-10.
Tradotto in parole, significa:
dormi con 30, mangi con 20,
compri prodotti agroalimentari con 10.
La seconda si chiama Shopping Face,
è curato da quattro ragazze,
l'hanno inventato
quattro ragazze di 17 anni.
E loro vendono ai commercianti
del territorio, agli esercenti,
il servizio di creare una pagina facebook
e gestire una pagina facebook.
Lo offrono ai commercianti
che non hanno o il tempo per farlo,
o le competenze per farlo.
Antonio Monaco, invece,
ha creato "Landware",
indossare il territorio.
Lui ha avuto un'intuizione,
un giorno, ed è venuto -
lo ricordo ancora, era un po' prima
degli esami di maturità, nel corridoio:
"Professore, ho avuto un'idea".
Allora, permettetemi un attimo
questo piccolo sfogo:
è bellissimo sentirselo dire.
Sono alcuni anni che io
vengo fermato nei corridoi
con: "Professore, ho avuto un'idea".
Quasi sempre gliela bocciamo,
ma qualche volta passa, questa idea.
Come nel caso di Antonio Monaco,
che ha avuto questa idea
di invertire una frase
che circola nel mondo da 37 anni.
37 anni fa fu inventata
questa frase vincente, "I Love New York".
"I Love New York"
è stata copiata in tutte le lingue,
è stata copiata per tutte le città
e per tutti i territori.
Antonio Monaco è stato
il primo a invertirlo.
Disse: "Professore, e se fosse il Salento
il primo territorio ad amare la persona,
e non ad essere amato?"
Ha creato la maglietta "Salento loves me".
Ha investito in questa idea 50 euro,
14 per stampare i due campioni,
qualche altra cosa per mettere
il carburante in macchina,
si è fatto il giro della penisola,
ha proposto la sua maglietta
tra i commercianti,
i commercianti hanno iniziato a ordinarla
e hanno cominciato a dare un acconto.
Con quell'acconto, lui ha pagato l'acconto
presso la fabbrica per stamparle,
e in questo modo è andato avanti.
E con questo investimento minimo iniziale,
nel giro di 20 giorni
è riuscito in parte a intascare,
come guadagno, oltre 1.500 euro.
Poi, ovviamente, la cosa è andata avanti
e ha continuato a lavorare.
Altri ragazzi, invece,
hanno inventato una carta:
una banalissima carta, "SKS",
una card per dare sconti agli studenti.
Questi ragazzi sono riusciti,
in poco tempo,
a convincere 80 negozi
a convenzionarsi con questa card,
[e] hanno venduto le card
a cinque euro l'una agli studenti.
E quindi hanno avuto una sorta
di doppia fonte d'ingresso:
da una parte i commercianti,
che spendevano 60-70 euro
per convenzionarsi per un anno,
e dall'altra, la vendita
delle card ai ragazzi.
Qui un'intera classe, invece,
si è improvvisata agenzia di viaggi.
Ma un'agenzia di viaggi particolare:
non è un'agenzia di viaggi normale.
È un'agenzia di viaggi specializzata
nelle gite turistiche scolastiche.
Quindi loro si rivolgevano
ai loro coetanei in tutta Italia
dicendo: "Ragazzi, perché per la gita
non venite giù in Salento?",
movimentando questa attività.
E quando arrivava il pullmann,
in città non c'erano degli adulti
ad accogliere questi ragazzi,
ma c'erano loro coetanei
che li accoglievano,
li portavano in albergo e li gestivano
durante il periodo della gita.
"Master Prof" è nata da pochi mesi:
è l'iniziativa di una classe
che ha voluto cercare, in tutta Italia,
tutti quei docenti "extra ordinari",
li chiamano fuori dall'ordinario,
che fanno delle cose un po' diverse.
Ecco, qui una piccola nota,
è nata dicendo:
"Professore, ma lei pensa di essere
l'unico che fa queste cose strane?
E ho detto: "Spero di no,
mi immagino sicuramente di no".
"E perché non li cerchiamo?"
"E perché no?"
Ed è quindi nato "Master Prof".
Oggi è online, questo sito.
In questo momento raccoglie, credo,
circa 150 docenti extraordinari.
L'olio Nectarea.
L'olio Nectarea è un olio
extravergine d'oliva;
qui la novità sta nella modalità
di commercializzazione dell'olio.
È un ottimo olio extravergine d'oliva,
ma sia il sito che il packaging
sono orientati a presentarlo
più come un prodotto
che dà dei benefici alla salute.
Perché l'olio extravergine d'oliva
lo sappiamo tutti, che dà dei benefici.
Ma questo viene venduto
per quei benefici.
E poi alla fine dice: "Se poi vuoi
anche usarlo in cucina, puoi anche farlo".
(Risate)
Antonio Scarnera è un fenomeno:
ha iniziato a 13-14 anni,
e ha avuto un'idea, un'intuizione:
ha creato un sito di vendita online
di servizi Internet -
è un po' più complicato,
vende spazio web, in pratica.
Soltanto, con questa intuizione
di venderlo ai suoi coetanei,
gente che non poteva spendere
più di 10, 15, 20 euro al massimo.
Questa è una storia simbolo,
perché oggi, non mi vergogno a dirlo,
anzi, a dir la verità
mi vergogno un po' a dirlo,
lui guadagna più di me.
(Risate)
Ha appena compiuto 18 anni,
lui guadagna più di me.
Smart Siti, l'ultimo nato.
Quattro mesi fa, quattro ragazzi,
due studenti oggi del quinto anno
e due neo diplomati,
si sono messi insieme
e realizzano siti Internet.
Quindi non è sbagliato
scrivere "Siti" in quel modo:
so che "Smart city"
viene scritto in un'altra maniera,
ma questo invece è stato fatto per scelta.
La caratteristica loro qual è?
La loro caratteristica
è che hanno deciso, e stanno facendo,
quello di confezionare
siti Internet per il cliente,
e lo confezionano addosso
come se fosse un lavoro sartoriale.
Infatti lo slogan, se leggete, è:
"La bottega artigiana del web".
Ci tengo a sottolineare
che tutte queste start-up,
tutte queste iniziative,
sono tutte realizzate
con un impegno iniziale,
o un finanziamento iniziale, bassissimo.
Non c'è nessuno che ha richiesto
un impegno importante.
Per due motivi: il primo è perché
non ce lo possiamo permettere,
siamo una scuola.
Il secondo è perché mi piace
che i ragazzi si sforzino
per trovare delle idee
che facciano più leva
su quello che sanno fare,
sulle loro capacità,
piuttosto che sul denaro.
E qui passiamo a quella
che è la seconda condivisione.
In questo caso, invece, i protagonisti
sono i nostri studenti, gli startupper.
Loro hanno iniziato
a condividere le loro storie
con i loro colleghi più giovani
della scuola media.
Da oltre un anno, infatti,
loro vanno nelle scuole,
entrano nelle aule dei ragazzi
di seconda e terza media
e raccontano loro le loro avventure.
Spiegano cosa hanno creato
e come l'hanno creato.
E che si tratti di una card
per avere degli sconti,
o di un nuovo servizio su facebook,
o di una nuova t-shirt,
l'effetto che riescono a suscitare
è sempre lo stesso:
un grande entusiasmo, una grande curiosità
e veramente un fascino a mille.
Noi abbiamo dato un nome,
a queste iniziative di condivisione.
È una sigla, sembra una formula chimica:
N2Y4B, never too young for business.
Mai troppo giovani per il business.
Ragazzi di 15-18 anni che insegnano,
condividono con ragazzi
più giovani, di 13-14 anni,
le loro esperienze imprenditoriali.
E la cosa funziona.
Adesso passiamo alla terza condivisione,
ve l'avevo annunciata all'inizio.
È una condivisione appena concepita;
sono stati due i fattori
che mi hanno spinto a pensarla.
Il primo fattore è stato il risultato
di un concorso internazionale.
Il secondo fattore, ancora una volta,
il bellissimo tema
di questo TEDx: "Share".
L'anno scorso ho partecipato
a un concorso internazionale,
ed è venuto fuori da questo concorso
che la nostra esperienze
fatte nel Salento, da oltre 15 anni,
di avviare studenti delle superiori,
quindi ragazzi sotto i 19 anni,
a creare impresa, a creare start up -
ecco, questa esperienza
è risultata essere unica
non solo in Italia, ma anche in Europa
e probabilmente in tutto il mondo.
E questa è una cosa straordinaria.
No, e invece no, non è straordinaria.
Dal mio punto di vista,
è infinitamente triste!
Perché io sono convinto
che tutti gli studenti,
permettetemi di sottolinearlo,
tutti gli studenti
che pensano di intraprendere
un corso di studi
con un indirizzo economico
abbiano il diritto;
dal mio punto di vista, il dovere,
ma abbiano il diritto di sperimentare,
con le proprie mani,
che cosa significa
creare e gestire un'impresa.
Che cosa significa
trattare con clienti e fornitori,
con ricavi, costi, con le banche.
E non farlo sotto forma di simulazione,
ma farlo nella pura realtà.
E allora questo palco,
oltre a essere testimone
di queste bellissime, straordinarie storie
che stiamo ascoltando insieme
è anche testimone di una storia nuova,
di una storia che deve essere
ancora scritta, ancora vissuta.
Perché abbiamo deciso
di condividere, da domani,
e quando intendo domani
intendo non domenica, ma lunedì;
da domani abbiamo deciso di condividere
le nostre esperienze, gli esercizi,
gli esempi di start-up
con il resto del paese,
con tutte le altre scuole in Italia,
con tutti gli altri docenti.
Pubblicheremo su un sito Internet
tutti questi esempi,
metteremo a disposizione
la nostra esperienza
per cercare di fare in modo
che questa esperienza
sia emulata e copiata.
Anche questo progetto ha un nome,
gli abbiamo dato un nome: Suite Lab.
Ancora una volta un acronimo:
"Incubatori di Start Up
degli Istituti Tecnici Economici".
Allora, adesso, permettermi di concludere
con una sorta di esortazione, un appello.
Ecco, voglio rivolgere un appello
a tutti i miei colleghi docenti,
a tutto il corpo docente italiano
di qualsiasi ordine e grado,
qualsiasi disciplina.
È una sorta di invito,
è un invito a quattro azioni.
Invito i miei colleghi
a innovare, a sperimentare, a creare.
Ma soprattutto, a condividere.
Grazie.
(Applausi)